step aside Kylie Jenner there's a new
fashion icon coming through
yes it's her two-year-old daughter
stormy Webster who stepped out rocking
personalized gold hoops probably to
remind us all it's Stormy's world and
we're just living in it I am obsessed
with it the toddler paired her statement
piece with an all-white in Samba on a
pair of Nike shoes girl is so impressed
by her look she's even checking herself
out in one of the many luxury cars mama
owns can Wednesday get any cuter yeah we
didn't think so Kylie captioned the
Instagram photos with go best friends
but the real sass came when Kylie tried
to take off her hoops yep stormy just
dodged her billionaire mama and said yep
Kylie wrote what have I started yep this
isn't the first time we've seen savage
stormy she said when the mother-daughter
duo watched frozen to for the first time
stormy told mama to zip it during the
movie so we're watching frozen too for
the first time
in July at the Pez I just turned to tell
our lover
you and me she said Chuck she's never
done that before
tell me to Shh
she'll be super nice but don't worry
stormy has a sweet side mm-hmm earlier
this week the two-year-old took care of
the make a mogul when she got her wisdom
teeth pulled out are you taking care of
me are you taking care of me
have you been takin care yeah nurse
stormy even made sure her mama could
walk down the stairs in her Louie
Vuitton slippers another mother and
daughter duo we can't get enough of
[Music]
yep Kim Kardashian in Northwest are
taking over tick-tock in the cute clip
we see North II press records before the
two start dancing together
et spoke with Kim and Kanye West at the
Vanity Fair Oscars party earlier this
month where she revealed they already
made other videos on the social media
app and North has a private tik-tok
account we do lots of tik toks together
and she puts them in drafts she's not
allowed to post up but we have lots of
tik toks I might post one soon
[Music]